This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”百分号，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回溯》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员和最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着西装革履或铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学步》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在iHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. On today's episode for our 12 days of guests, I want to talk about something that I have really wanted to speak to since the day I started this podcast.
欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听另一期节目。当然，我们要剖析我们二十多岁的心理。在今天关于我们12天嘉宾的节目中，我想聊聊一件自我创办这个播客之日起就一直非常想谈的事情。
I remember this very topic being on my first ever list of topics that I wanted to cover. And it's still been on that list since 2021, but I knew I needed to find the right guests to talk about it. Today we're finally getting to it. We're going to be tackling a topic that runs very deep, which is sexism or misogyny in our. 20s, in our workplaces, in our friendships, in dating, but also our own internalized misogyny
我记得这个话题曾在我的第一份想探讨的话题清单上。自2021年以来，它就一直列在清单上，但我知道我需要找到合适的嘉宾来谈论它。今天我们终于要讲到了。我们将探讨一个非常深入的话题，那就是我们二十多岁时的性别歧视或厌女症，在我们的工作场所，在我们的友谊中，在约会中，还有我们自己内化的厌女症。
and how to deal with that. What are some of the psychological consequences of experiencing misogyny during this decade? How do you put your foot down? How do you stand up for yourself when you don't feel like you have power? What does it mean when other women tear each other down? Why do we criticize each other? There's so many behaviors and beliefs and systems attached to this, but at the end of the day it is quite a psychological experience. It's rooted in social structures and messaging that has been ingrained in us since a young age. And I'm really excited to explore the psychology behind these patterns and this experience. And also to welcome on our amazing expert guest, a friend of the show, Hannah Ferguson.
以及如何应对。在这个十年里经历厌女症有哪些心理后果？你该如何表明强硬态度？当你觉得自己没有权力时，如何为自己挺身而出？当其他女性互相贬低时，这意味着什么？我们为什么要互相批评？有这么多的行为、信仰和系统与此相关，但归根结底，这是一种相当心理学的体验。它植根于从小就根植于我们心中的社会结构和信息。我真的很高兴能探索这些模式和经历背后的心理学。同时也要欢迎我们出色的专家嘉宾，节目老朋友汉娜·弗格森。
Friend of the show, I love that. I am a friend of the show, genuinely. Yeah, before this, we were just having like a massive, massive chat. then we're like, wait, we actually have a job to do. Yeah, and that's crazy because we're in the depths right now of each other's personal lives. Let's snap back into reality and get into the questions. I love that energy, though. I know.
节目的老朋友，我喜欢这个。我真的是节目的老朋友。对，在此之前，我们刚刚进行了非常非常深入的聊天。然后我们说，等等，我们其实还有工作要做。对，这太疯狂了，因为我们现在正深入了解彼此的个人生活。让我们回到现实中来，开始回答问题。不过我喜欢这种活力。我知道。
I know. This is like true female bonding. Like we're talking about misogy and there's like none of it here. It's not present in the room with us right now. No, I know. Also, it's so nice to have an Australian guest on. I'm so privileged to be here. Thank you.
我知道。这就像真正的女性情谊。就像我们在谈论厌女症，这里完全没有那种东西。此时此刻这个房间里并不存在。不，我知道。另外，能有一位澳大利亚嘉宾来真是太好了。我很荣幸能来到这里。谢谢。
And we're in the same room. For once. I know. I think this never happens with a guest, like very, very rarely. Can you tell the listeners, a little bit about who you are, what you do. It's like a complete rap sheet and how you got here. So I am the founder and CEO of Cheek MediaCo, which is mainly a sort of news commentary platform for left-wing opinions through Instagram, so at cheekmedia.com. I'm also the co-host of
而且我们在同一个房间里。破天荒。我知道。我觉得嘉宾来这种情况几乎从不会发生，非常非常罕见。你能向听众介绍一下你是谁，你是做什么的。这就像一张完整的犯罪记录以及你是怎么走到这一步的。我是Cheek MediaCo的创始人和首席执行官，这主要是一个通过Instagram发表左翼观点的某种新闻评论平台，网址是cheekmedia.com。我还是新闻和流行文化播客《Big Small Talk》的联合主持人。
News and Pop Culture Podcast Big Small Talk. And I'm the best-selling author of Byteback and my new book taboo has just come out as well. And that's really about sex, dating relationships. And like what it means to be a woman in 2024. And bite back, for those of you who have not read that book, incredible. My mum read that book. Oh, that's really nice. Yeah, I bought it for her and she was like, this is incredible. Oh, I love that.
我是畅销书《Byteback》的作者，我的新书《Taboo》也刚出版。这本书真正关乎性、约会关系。以及在2024年作为一个女人意味着什么。对于那些没有读过那本书的人来说，《Bite back》太不可思议了。我妈妈读了那本书。哦，那真的很好。是的，我买给她读的，她说：“这太不可思议了。”哦，我喜欢这个。
And bite back. It's a book about feminism, media, and politics and how we change the systems. Yeah, which is literally the perfect segue into what we're talking about today, which is misogyny. And of course, you talk about this a lot, both on cheek, but also on a podcast, in your books, I want to really begin by focusing on misogyny from women to women. Yep. Because I think that's like the most complex issue that I wrap my head around.
还有《Bite back》。这是一本关于女性主义、媒体和政治的书，以及我们如何改变这些系统。是的，这简直是完美过渡到我们今天的话题——厌女症。当然，你经常谈论这个，无论是在Cheek上，还是在播客中，在你的书中，我想一开始就重点关注女性对女性的厌女症。是的。因为我认为这是我能想通的最复杂的问题。
It's like you kind of expect misogyny from men at times, but never from someone perhaps of your same gender who understands your experience. How do you think it kind of looks different? What do we like typically expect misogyny to look like versus what are the ways that we actually encounter it. Yeah, and like for people, and I think it's really important to make the note at the start that misogyny is the hatred of women, of femininity, of these sort of traits that we consider and associate with women and girls. And I think that needs to be really contrast against sexism, which is just a singular act. So misogyny is this deep rooted hatred, right? And when it's experienced towards ourselves, when it's experienced towards other women as women and girls, it's called
有时候你会有所预料男性的厌女症，但绝不会来自一个或许与你性别相同、理解你的经历的人。你认为它看起来有什么不同吗？我们通常期望厌女症是什么样的，而我们实际遇到它的方式又是什么样的？是的，而且对于人们来说，我认为在一开始指出这一点非常重要，即厌女症是对女性、对女性气质、对我们认为并与妇女和女孩联系在一起的这些特质的仇恨。我认为这需要与性别歧视形成鲜明对比，性别歧视只是一种单一的行为。所以厌女症是一种根深蒂固的仇恨，对吧？当它在我们自己身上经历时，当它作为妇女和女孩对其他女性经历时，它被称为
internalized misogyny because we are internalizing a system of patriarchy that has conditioned us to see women and girls as less than, less than men. And it's anyone who really, it's the gender spectrum, it's people who are not men and how we are treated as less than as in equal to men, and then how we apply that kind of thinking that's been conditioned into us since birth towards ourselves and other women and girls. So it could be, and there's so many examples of this, but I would say like the beauty industry and body image standards, the way we feel about ourselves and treat ourselves about our bodies, that's an act of internalised misogyny, the way that we judge other women.
内化的厌女症，因为我们内化了一个父权制系统，该系统让我们习惯于将妇女和女孩视为不如人，不如男性。而且这确实适用于任何人，这是性别光谱，是不属于男性的那些人，以及我们如何被视为低人一等、不如男性，然后我们如何将这种自出生起就被灌输给我们的思维方式应用到我们自己以及其他妇女和女孩身上。所以它可能是，这方面的例子有很多，但我会说是美容行业和身体形象标准，我们对自己的看法以及对待自己身体的方式，这是内化厌女症的一种行为，我们评判其他女性的方式。
And I'm not saying just general judgment. Of course we're going to have natural judgment and criticism for others. But internalized misogyny is really focusing on feminized parts of ourselves and qualities, traits, behaviors that patriarchy shames and oppresses those things in other women that we critique. So maybe the way someone wears their hair, the way someone does their makeup, their body,
我并不是说只是一般的评判。当然，我们对他人会有自然的评判和批评。但内化的厌女症实际上聚焦于我们身上女性化的部分，以及那些父权制羞辱和压迫的品质、特质、行为，我们在其他女性身上批评这些东西。所以也许是某人的发型，某人的化妆方式，他们的身体，
their opinion on feminism. The way that we treat other women in those senses is internalised misogyny coming out. And I really like how you pointed out that it's almost a hatred of things that are typically female. Yeah.
他们对女性主义的观点。我们在这些意义上对待其他女性的方式就是内化厌女症的表现。我真的很喜欢你指出这几乎是对通常属于女性的事物的仇恨。是的。
So it's not like, oh, I hate their body the way that, oh, you know, I'm judging their body, the way that you can judge anyone's body. It's, I'm judging their body because they are a woman or because of something about them that seems feminine or seems maybe sexual. So it's like, you know, it's a double standard.
所以这不像，哦，我讨厌他们的身材，就像，哦，你知道，我在评判他们的身材，就像你可以评判任何人的身材一样。而是，我评判他们的身材是因为他们是女性，或者因为他们身上某些看起来很女性化或可能显得性感的东西。所以就像，你知道，这是双重标准。
That's the word that always is like, is it the heart of any conversation around this? It's there is one world for women and girls, people who identify as women. And then there is this other world for people who aren't women, who are men. The standard is raised. There's a different set of criteria. There's things that you notice every single day
这就是那个总是成为围绕这话题的任何对话核心的词？对于妇女和女孩、认同为女性的人来说，有一个世界。然后对于那些不是女性、是男性的人来说，有另一个世界。标准提高了。有一套不同的标准。这是你每天都能注意到的事情
and apply criticism to that you would never focus on for men. And it feels so weird when that's coming from another woman. Yes. Like it's so strange when you're like, wait, I thought we were meant to be like buddies here. Oh, my God. And you can feel it in your bones when I'm talking about it. You know, when you go to a lunch with your family and your grandma points out that you've put on weight or that you're eating too much or that your skirt or your hair or something, ripped jeans.
并对其进行批评，而你绝不会对男性这样做。当这种批评来自另一个女性时，感觉太奇怪了。是的。就像当你觉得，等等，我以为我们在这里应该是好朋友时，感觉太奇怪了。哦，天哪。当我谈到这个时，你能从骨子里感受到它。你知道，当你和家人去吃午饭时，你奶奶指出你长胖了，或者你吃得太多了，或者你的裙子、头发或什么的，破洞牛仔裤。
Like there are so many examples of like different qualities, traits, behaviors, again, that are like, you would never see that happen to your brother, your cousin who's male. Like you can see and feel the difference in the moment about the standard women are held to. Have you ever had any experiences of this? Like, have you ever? It's a rhetorical question. To do the run sheet, yeah. Yeah.
像这样的例子有很多，不同的品质、特质、行为，再次强调，就像，你永远不会看到这种事发生在你的兄弟、身为男性的表弟身上。就像你可以当场看到并感受到女性所承受的标准上的差异。你经历过这种事吗？比如，你曾有过吗？这是一个反问句。为了走流程，对吧。是的。
Like, what was your reaction there? You know, being torn down by another woman and obviously you have like an online presence, right? It happens all the time. Yeah. Was it pity, anger or like sadness? What's the main emotional reaction for you? I feel like there's obviously like a spectrum and like a pattern of behaviour as to how this runs for me.
就像，你当时的反应是什么？你知道，被另一个女性贬低，而且显然你拥有网络影响力，对吧？这经常发生。是的。是同情、愤怒还是悲伤？对你来说，主要的统情绪反应是什么？我觉得这里面显然有一个光谱和行为模式，说明这对我来说是如何运作的。
So firstly, it's like rage and I'm offended, right? I'm obviously hurt. I'm wounded. And at first, it's this I am being unfairly targeted and something is being pointed out about my appearance or it feels like it's tied inherently to my identity because that's the other thing. Women's identity and appearance is so inherently linked. So so many of these feminized characteristics feel like an attack on your own.
所以首先，就像是愤怒，我被冒犯了，对吧？我显然受到了伤害。我受伤了。起初，这是一种我被不公正地针对的感觉，我的外表有什么地方被指出来了，或者感觉它本质上与我的身份绑定在一起，因为这是另一回事。女性的身份和外表是如此内在紧密地联系在一起。因此，许多这些女性化的特征感觉就像是对你自身的攻击。
your personhood, your humanity, right? There's this rage that something so personal is being criticized. Then it turns for me to a particular kind of hurt. And that hurt is, when men make comments about my body, they do so because they feel entitled to do that and they've never had my lived experience. It hurts more from women. Fair or not, it hurts more for women for me personally because I know that they know what it feels like. Oh my gosh, right? And so it hurts more because you expect understanding and you know empathy is present. You know empathy is possible. And so to have them use it and weaponise it against you feel so deeply wounding, then it turns to pity for me. Because I realized that at some point in their life, they felt it was so shameful
你的人格，你的人性，对吧？有一种愤怒，因为如此私密的事情受到了批评。然后对我来说，它变成了一种特定类型的伤害。这种伤害是，当男性对我的身体发表评论时，他们这样做是因为他们觉得自己有权这样做，而且他们从未有过我的人生经历。从女性那里听到这话更让人受伤。不管公平与否，对我个人来说，从女性那里听到这话更让我受伤，因为我知道她们知道那种感觉是什么样的。哦，天哪，对吧？所以这更令人受伤，因为你期望得到理解，你知道同理心是存在的。你知道同理心是可能的。因此，让她们利用这一点并将其武器化来对付你，感觉是如此深深的刺痛，然后对我来说，它变成了同情。因为我意识到在她们生命中的某个时刻，她们觉得
to lean into these parts of themselves that they instead decided to become and lean into masculine patriarchal tactics and use it against me. And I feel sorry for them that that happened. It's like a full closure circle as well. I like that you kind of finish on pity because what is more winning than pity? I think about that all the time. I guess my problem though is when pity doesn't lead to should I challenge this? Yeah, that's a good point. I think I don't because I know that especially like online, I'm like, the system that have made you this run a lot deeper than what I can handle on an Instagram comment. Of course.
倾向于自己身上的这些部分是如此可耻，以至于她们反而决定成为并倾向于男性的父权制策略，并用它来对付我。我为她们发生了这种事感到遗憾。这也是一个完全闭环。我喜欢你最后以同情结束，因为还有什么比同情更有力呢？我一直在想这件事。我想我的问题在于，当同情没有转化为“我应该挑战这个吗？”时。是的，说得好。我想我没有这样做，因为我知道，尤其是网上的言论，我觉得：让你变成这样的系统比我能在Instagram评论区处理的要深得多。当然。
So I'm going to be pulled in and I'm just going to feel worse and people might look at that and actually become even more angry. It's a hard. It's a hard job, isn't it? It's circumstantial. It depends on what you think you can do with that certain comment. And often the only reason I'll comment back to someone on Instagram is if I think that my comment can employ like a certain tone and emotion, that it's not necessarily to convince the person commenting, but for other people watching to know and learn how to articulate how to do that.
所以我会深陷其中，结果只会感觉更糟，人们可能会看到这一点并变得更加愤怒。这是一项艰巨的工作，不是吗？这要视情况而定。这取决于你认为你能对那个特定的评论做些什么。通常我会在Instagram上回复别人的唯一原因，是我认为我的评论可以运用某种基调和情感，这不一定是为了说服发表评论的人，而是为了让其他围观的人知道并学会如何表达该如何应对。
Yeah. I only ever do it as like, okay, if I'm going to call this person in, I need to make sure it's in a sense and in a way that I think others could benefit from too, not just this person. See, my approach is like just be so absolutely deliciously kind to them that they then are like, oh, wait, am I the asshole here? Yeah. And I'm like, actually this is going to make you really the reflective.
是的。我这么做从来都只是为了，好吧，如果我要指出这个人的问题，我需要确保它的语气和方式是我认为其他人也能从中受益的，而不仅仅是这个人。你看，我的方法就是对他们绝对、极度地友善，以至于他们接着会想：“哦，等等，我是个混蛋吗？”是的。然后我想，实际上这会让你真正进行反思。
back hopefully. Also, you can't go anywhere else. Once, I honestly think that like kindness or even like complete knowledge or education, it just corners someone and you're like, you can't hurt me anymore. Like there is, there is nothing more that you can do. I've exited this conversation. I've left my like, sparkly fairy dust or I've left my knowledge and I'm not going to respond to this anymore. Yeah. And you're so right. I feel like when you get comments from men, I'm like, you're going to hate me no matter what. And one of my friends, Violet, actually, who, has a bit of like an online presence. I was getting like all these mean comments,
希望如此。此外，你无处可去。有一次，我真心觉得，善良甚至是完全的知识或教育，只会把一个人逼入绝境，你会觉得：你再也不能伤害我了。就像，没有，没有什么是你再能做的了。我已经退出了这段对话。我留下了我亮晶晶的仙女尘，或者我留下了我的知识，我不会再对此做出回应了。是的。你说得太对了。我觉得当你收到男性的评论时，我想：无论如何你都会讨厌我。我的朋友维奥莱特实际上，她有一定的网络影响力，
maybe like midway through this year, had like a random video go viral. If you remember, it was like, remember that turns like, I'm looking for a man in finance. And the video that I posted was like, I'm just looking for a man in therapy. He can be anyone, any size, any eyes.
大概在今年年中左右，有一个随机视频突然爆火。如果你还记得的话，就像，还记得那个梗，我在找一个有金融背景的男人。而我发布的视频是：我只是在找一个做心理治疗的男人。他可以是任何人，任何体型，任何眼睛。
I just want him to be self-aware. Yep. And I did not think that that was a controversial thing to be saying, oh my God, did I get ripped apart? by all these men and they were like well your teeth are terrible well you're fat well you're this that uh like you have all these terrible qualities and then it was like these women being like yeah get her and my friend violet was like they're going to say that to you no matter what you look like no matter who you are because they have learned that to be a woman that's an insult they go
我只想让他有自我意识。是的。我不认为这是一个充满争议的言论，哦，天哪，我有没有被撕碎？被所有这些男人撕碎，他们说：嗯，你的牙齿真烂，嗯，你很胖，嗯，你是这个那个，就像你有很多糟糕的品质，然后还有这些女性说：对，搞她！我的朋友维奥莱特就说：无论你长什么样，无论你是谁，他们都会对你说这些，因为他们已经学会了，作为一个女人，这就是一种侮辱，他们直接
done like you're already just the fact of being like anything you do is an insult anything that you if there is woman or female or girl before it or she or her is offensive in their eyes. But what's ironic is that so many men constantly talk about the need for men's mental health to be prioritised and acknowledged. And yes, your video is in the like meme viral moment. But all you were asking for was I want men to engage in mental health practices and to have a level of self-awareness and emotional intelligence, which is quite a low bar, an expectation, right? It's nothing to physical appearance. It's purely psychological and well-being related. And to have a level of self-awareness. And to have a level of,
完成了，就像你已经——仅仅是身为女性这个事实——你做的任何事都是一种侮辱，你做的任何事，如果前面有女人、女性或女孩，或者在她眼里的她或她的代词，在他们看来都是具有攻击性的。但讽刺的是，许多男性不断谈论需要优先考虑和承认男性心理健康的需求。是的，你的视频正处于梗爆红的时刻。但你所要求的只是——我希望男性参与心理健康实践，并具备一定程度的自我意识和情商，这其实是一个很低的门槛和期望，对吧？它与外表无关，纯粹与心理和福祉有关。并且具备一定程度的自我意识。并且具备一定程度的，
that turned on you is proving the point one, but also establishing that men's standards for women and nothing to do with our emotional health or what we can bring to the table in our personal lives and all to do. And it's not to say all men, obviously. Yeah. But it's to say that the response was purely appearance-based proves how little therapy that those people have done. Yeah, exactly. Right. That was one of the main comments was this guy. It was like, well, then why would I want you? And I was like, you've literally just proved my point. Yep. Like, you just proved it like in a second that you, this is the person who needs this. Like the fact that it's not even a demand, it's like, I'm looking for this.
这种言论反噬到你身上，一方面证明了这一点，另一方面也确立了男性对女性的标准与我们的情感健康或我们在个人生活中能带来什么毫无关系，而完全与……这并不是说所有男性都这样，显然。是的。但这是为了说明，回应纯粹是基于外表的，这证明了那些人做过多么少的心理治疗。是的，完全正确。主要的评论之一就是这个家伙。就像：那我还为什么要你？我说：你刚才正好证明了我的观点。是的。就像你在一秒钟内证明了，你，这就是需要这个的人。就像事实上这甚至不是一个要求，而是：我在找这个。
You don't have to be this. I'm looking for this. This is a joke. This is like a viral hook. And you're taking it so personally that you've like insulted me. Anyhow, we've gotten completely off track. The people that really interested me though in that comment section was the women, was the women who were like, God, that's just like, why would you want such a feminine man? Why would you want someone who like, why would I want a man in therapy?
你不需要成为这样的人。我在找这个。这是一个笑话。这是一个病毒式的噱头。而你却如此走心以至于你侮辱了我。无论如何，我们完全偏离正题了。不过在评论区里真正让我感兴趣的是女性，是那些说：天哪，那简直是——你为什么会想要一个这么女性化的男人？你为什么会想要一个像——我为什么会想要一个做心理治疗的男人？
All of these things. And that kind of brings me to talking about the pick me girl. Because when you're explaining your kind of your cycle of truth when you get a hate comment from another woman, it ends in sympathy. And I honestly feel so much sympathy towards pick me girls. And I want to see if you feel the same way. What does that, what does a pick me girl look like to you though? A pick me girl sits alongside terms like cool girl or not. not like other girls. There's a really fantastic additional phrase that was coined by Australian
所有这些事情。这就把我带到了谈论“求关注女孩”（pick me girl）。因为当你解释你收到另一个女性的恨意评论时的真理循环时，它以同情告终。老实说，我对“求关注女孩”感到非常同情。我想看看你是否有同感。对你来说，“求关注女孩”是什么样子的？“求关注女孩”与“酷女孩”或“不
journalist Amy Ramikas, which is a crumb maiden. A crumb maiden being someone who rises up within systems and uses that very system and that power to oppress a group that they're part of. Julie Bishop. Perfect. Sorry, just going to add her. People who aren't Australian won't know who that is. Julie Bishop and Pauline Hanson, if you are in Australia, if you're not Australia, have a Google. Yeah, raise your hands. The search goes up. But I think that the way to think of a pick-me girl, and when we say pick-me, it's this woman who wants to be chosen by men. So this is a woman in our minds who engages and prioritises male attention, male interests, the male gaze, in order to garner attention and approval from men to the exclusion of women.
像其他女孩”这样的词并列。澳大利亚记者艾米·拉米卡斯创造了一个非常棒的附加短语，叫做“面包屑少女”（a crumb maiden）。“面包屑少女”是指那些在系统内部崛起并利用该系统和权力来压迫她们所属群体的某类人。朱莉·毕晓普。完美。抱歉，我只是想加上她。不是澳大利亚人的人不会知道那是谁。如果你在澳大利亚，朱莉·毕晓普和 Pauline Hanson，如果你不在澳大利亚，谷歌一下。是的，举起手来。搜索量上升了。但我认为考虑“求关注女孩”的方式，当我们说“求关注”时，这个女性想要被男性选择。所以在我们心中，这是一个为了获得男性的关注和认可，从而将男性的关注、男性的利益、男性的凝视置于优先地位，以至于排挤女性的女性。
So to distance themselves from groups of girls to not want to be a girl's girl, in quotations, and someone who really pursues systems of patriarchy to find themselves more privileged than other women within that system. And it's honestly very, very interesting because I think once you start noticing it, you're like, oh, sometimes I do that. Yeah. Sometimes, and I can see myself having done that when I was younger a lot. Well, I think that starting from a place of sympathy towards this, when you're a teenage girl, I've never met someone who didn't engage in pick me girl behavior. Yeah.
因此，为了将自己与女孩群体拉开距离，不想做一个“女孩的好闺蜜”（加引号），并且是真正追求父权制系统以在系统内发现自己比其他女性拥有更多特权的人。老实说，这非常非常有趣，因为我认为一旦你开始注意到这一点，你就会想：哦，有时我也会那样做。是的。有时，我能看到自己年轻时经常这样做。好吧，我认为从对这一现象抱持同情开始，当你还是一个十几岁的女孩时，我从未遇到过没有参与过“求关注女孩”行为的人。是的。
Because we've got to really step back from this and understand that the idea of a pick me is that they want to be chosen. They want to be love. They want to be seen to an extent, right, by men. And we exist in a society that teaches women from a very young age that the worst thing they could be a single and child free. So in that context, of course, young girls, especially in our early teen years and as we become adults, really lean in to, I need to have a little. boyfriend, I need to be desirable. To be seen to be loved means in a patriarchal society for women to be beautiful and enticing to men.
因为我们必须真正从这种心态中退一步，明白“求关注者”的想法是她们想要被选择。她们想要被爱。在某种程度上，她们希望被男性看见，对吧？我们生活在一个社会中，从小就教导女性，最糟糕的事情就是单身且没有孩子。所以在这种背景下，年轻女孩，尤其是在我们的青春期早期以及当我们成为成年人时，确实倾向于：我需要有一个小男友，我需要有吸引力。在父权制社会中，被看到被爱意味着女性对男性来说是美丽的、诱人的。
And that takes a lot of time to sort of dismantle, to de-centre that need. And it takes a lot of self-awareness and growth. You know, what's really fascinating was I was talking to one of my friends about this and she's recently come out as a lesbian. And I was bringing this up. I was like, I'm going to go talk to Hannah about pick me girls. Like, do you think that like this impacted you despite you never really feeling like any kind of sexual desire towards men? And she was like, yes. Yeah. 100%. She was like, even as a teenager,
这需要花费大量时间来解构，来将这种需求去中心化。这需要大量的自我意识和成长。你知道，非常迷人的是，我和我的一个朋友谈起过这件事，她最近刚出柜为女同性恋。我提出了这一点。我说：我要去和汉娜谈谈“求关注女孩”。就像，你认为这会影响到你吗？尽管你从未真正对男性产生过任何生理欲望？她说：是的。是的。100%。她说：甚至作为一个青少年，
I did all these things because I wanted and she had boyfriends and she wanted a boyfriend. She's like, I had absolutely no sexual interest in them. But there was a part of me, almost this like, part of me in my DNA that realized that winning the favor and the approval of men would benefit me, would be powerful for me, would offer me like some form of protection. you know like if I was chosen maybe I was not going to be judged as much maybe I would be protected from scrutiny so it's really fascinating to recognize that it doesn't just come down to yeah sex arousal like romantic attachment it is actually a level deeper than that psychologically and it has to do with power and safety and security and I never thought that I'd find myself like
我做了所有这些事情，因为我想要——而且她有过男朋友，她想要一个男朋友。她说：我对他们完全没有生理兴趣。但有那么一瞬间，几乎就像是我DNA里的这部分意识到，赢得男性的青睐和认可会让我受益，会对我很有力量，会为我提供某种形式的保护。你知道的，如果我被选中了，也许我就不会受到那么多的评判，也许我可以免受审查，所以很高兴认识到，它并不仅仅归结为性唤起、浪漫依恋，它实际上比这更深一层，在心理上与权力和安全感有关。我从未想过自己会发现自己对那些五六十岁还在“求关注”的女孩产生同情，但我心想：你是在一个环境中和一个社会中长大的，在那里，你的其他选择是什么？而且我们仍然（你知道）生活在一个社会中，我有选择不要孩子的单身朋友，我有很多单身朋友，但我们仍在开辟道路，因为虽然女性长期以来一直选择这样做，但这从未成为多数，甚至从未达到三分之一，甚至连四分之一都没有，作为女性，这种生活方式从未真正可见，也没有那么明显，所以我们不知道拥有整个朋友圈是什么样的，
sympathizing with like the pick me girls who were like freaking 50 and 60 but I'm like you were raised in an environment and in a society where what was your other option and we still you know we exist in a society where I have friends who have chosen to be child free I have lots of single friends but we are still kind of charting the course for the first time because while women have been choosing to do this for a long time it's never been the majority it's never been a third it's never even been a quarter of women really visible as well as visible so we don't know what it looks like to have entire friendship circles and, you know, context where women are invited to really challenge those milestones because women have been taught that the most valuable parts of
以及女性被邀请真正挑战这些里程碑的背景，因为女性被教导她们生活中最有价值的部分，她们的里程碑是那些放弃自主权和独立性的事情。婚姻、孩子。当你真正深入思考这一点时，我们最受庆祝和被捧上高座的事情，正是那些我们放弃自由的事情。而且很难不买账这个系统，因为——这并不是说，如果你想要孩子，如果你想结婚，你就某种程度上是反女权主义的什么的。这是一个你做出的选择，
their lives, that their milestones are things where they give up agency and independence. Marriage, children. Like, when you really think about that, the things we are most celebrated and pedestalled for are the things where we revoke our freedom. And it's hard to not buy into that system because, and this isn't to say that, if you want children and if you want to be married, that somehow you're like anti-feminist or whatever. It's a choice that, like, you know, you make,
你做的每一个选择，你都在放弃一些东西。是的。不仅仅是我们正在谈论的这些。任何选择，比如工作。我们在放弃时间。我们在放弃，你知道，那是劳动。那需要大量的脑力空间。就像当我们思考我们正在做的很多事情时，
every single choice you make, you give up something. Yeah. Not just to do with what we're talking about. Any choice for anything, like work. We're giving up time. We're giving up, you know, that's labor. That's a lot of brain space. Like when we think about lots of things that we're doing,
它总是做出这样的选择。买任何东西，你都在放弃用这些钱买其他东西的可能性。所以，这并非出于评判。但我确实认为，看到很多女性说：哦，也许那不是我想要的。也许那不是我想要的。以前，（你知道）我的母亲、我的祖母、我的祖先都没有得到这种选择。而这么多人正在拥抱这一点，表明有时可能存在一种更深层次的渴望，即不想要那些东西，而过去，如果我们让这种渴望更早地表现出来，它会变得更正常。
it's always making a choice like that. Buying anything, you're giving up the possibility of buying something else with that money. Like, so it's not, it doesn't come from a place of judgment. But I do think that it's very interesting to see that, a lot of women are like, oh, maybe that's not what I want. Maybe that's not what I want. And previously, you know, my mother, my grandmother, my ancestors were not given that choice. And the fact that so many people are embracing that shows that maybe there is a deeper desire to not have those things at times that previously, it would have been more normalized if we'd let that desire be more
是的。而那些没有这种渴望的人，也会过得很好。就像，每个人都可以做他们他妈的想做的事，无论那个选择是什么。我认为这是一个非常重要的转折点。我们要稍事休息，但当我们回来时，我们将讨论如何摆脱我们自己内化的厌女症，如何应对职场中的厌女症，如何坚定自信，如何自信、直言不讳、大声说出来、勇敢索求你想要的东西。所有这些以及更多内容，就在这段简短的广告之后。《2%》。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等对话，抛弃主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，
present earlier. Yes. And the people who didn't desire, that would have been fine as well. Like, everyone would have just been able to do whatever the fuck they wanted, whatever that choice was. And I think that's like a really important place that we're getting to. We're going to take a short break, but when we return, we're to discuss how to unlearn some of our own internalized misogyny, deal with misogyny in the workplace, how to assert ourselves, how to be confident, be outspoken, be loud, ask for what you want. All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when
之前已经呈现过了。是的。那些不想这么做的人也没问题。就像，每个人都可以做任何他们他妈的想做的事，无论做出什么选择。我认为这是一个非常重要的转折点。我们稍作休息，回来后将讨论如何消除我们内心对女性的根深蒂固的厌恶，如何应对职场中的厌女症，如何坚定立场、建立自信、直抒己见、大声表达，以及如何争取你想要的东西。休息之后，还有更多精彩内容。2%。这就是选择走楼梯的人的比例，当
there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”百分号。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍打小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're doing. thinking, what the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回溯》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在节目里聊聊快克，但只是为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me,
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学步》，我是你
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
的主持人，你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。我们仍在追逐它，却不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。你觉得在人间走一遭，做一个好人重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app.
你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难学步》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
搜索《艰难学步》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中显而易见的不一致之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
The Gillespie and Michael Marangini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen,
吉尔斯比和迈克尔·马朗吉尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，
breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. All right. So we're back with Hannah. And I have another question for you. Of course, because this is an interview. So that's how that works. I'm out now, but I'm just going to sit here. Yeah. So I'm just going to monologue. Speaking of monolog, when our internal monologue is really saying,
马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。好的。我们现在和汉娜一起回来了。我还有个问题要问你。当然，因为这是一场采访。事情就是这样的。我现在不说话了，但我会坐在这里。是的。所以我要发表独白了。说到独白，当我们的内心独白真实地在说：
okay, there are certain things I need to do to be accepted in this environment to be picked. You know, I do want love and I want to get married. Is that going to cost me giving up certain things? should I just not be myself? How do we counteract that narrative that is very much, I think, maybe like rooted in our own internalized misogyny, the narrative that you have to be different or you have to suppress the parts of you that are, you know, female or that are individual in order to fit into like society's box?
好吧，有些事情我必须做，才能在这个环境中被接受，才能被选中。你知道，我的确想要爱情，我想结婚。这会让我付出放弃某些东西的代价吗？我是不是不该做自己？我们如何反击那种很大程度上根植于我们自己内化的厌女症的叙事，那种认为你必须与众不同，或者你必须压抑自己身上那些女性化的或个性的部分，以便融入社会框架的叙事？
I had this quote a few months ago in an interview on the Imperfects podcast. We love them. We love them. And the quote was one of the celebrities interviewed said, the more me I am, the better it goes. And I think about that a lot in the context of the way I choose relationships and which work opportunities to pursue. Because I don't want to say to anyone, stop repressing everything, stop compromising. But like the nature of relationships is that we're going to have conflict. We're going to have compromise.
几个月前我在《The Imperfects》播客的一场采访中引用了这句话。我们爱他们。我们爱他们。这句话是，采访的一位名人说：“我越是做自己，一切就越顺利。”在选择人际关系和追求哪些工作机会的背景下，我经常思考这句话。因为我不想对任何人说：停止压抑一切，停止妥协。但人际关系的本质就是我们要经历冲突。我们要妥协。
We're going to have boundaries. We're going to have needs and wants. when we're talking about our own internal monologue of like being the cool girl or, you know, suppressing our femininity or performing in a certain way, we can understand that beauty standards under patriarchy and the male gays have a very specific idea of what is hot. But the person you actually want to be with and the person that is best for you if you choose, so choose or so seek long-term relationships, partnered, monogamous, whatever that may be, is the person that sees you as. you want to be seen and allow yourself to be seen. Because I think that part of my issue, especially in my own personal life of dating, was for so long, I was so worried, especially running a feminist media company. Kungalwamara. Was that every time I told a man, they'd be like, oh, I find your success hot, but not your
我们要有界限。我们要有需求和愿望。当我们谈论我们内心关于做“酷女孩”的独白时，或者（你知道）压抑我们的女性气质或以某种方式表演，我们可以理解父权制和男性凝视下的美丽标准对什么是“火辣”有着非常具体的概念。但如果你选择寻找长期关系、伴侣关系、一夫一妻制或无论那可能是什么，你真正想要与之在一起的人以及最适合你的人，其实是那个把你视作你想成为的那样、并允许你做自己的人。因为我认为我的一部分问题，特别是在我自己的约会个人生活中，很长时间以来我都非常担心，尤其是在经营一家女性主义媒体公司时。昆加拉马拉。就是每当我告诉一个男人时，他们都会说：哦，我觉得你的成功很火辣，但并不觉得你
personality and your values. Like, I was so worried about the sort of, are they truly here for the right reasons and actually align with me. And they don't have to align with everything, I think. That's not what we're aiming for either. what we're aiming for is to be so comfortable with ourselves and what we want and who we're looking for in our lives, that we go and actually allow ourselves to seek out that person by being honest with ourselves about what it will take for us to be seen and loved in the way that we want. I know that I engaged in a lot of bad relationships because I performed what I thought I was supposed to do and it never made me feel good. And also just out of a need for validation at times as well. Absolutely.
个性以及你的价值观。就像，我曾经非常担心那种，他们真的是出于正确的理由来到这里的吗，而且真的跟我合拍吗。而且我觉得他们不需要在所有事情上都跟我合拍。这也不是我们的目标。我们的目标是让我们对自己、对我们想要什么、对我们在生活中寻找什么感到如此舒适，以至于我们去寻找那个人，并通过对自己诚实——为了让我们以我们想要的方式被看到和被爱需要付出什么——来真正允许自己去寻找那个人。我知道我陷入过很多糟糕的关系中，因为我表现出我认为我应该做的事情，而这从来没有让我感觉好过。而且有时候也仅仅是出于对认可的需求。完全同意。
You can have like all the knowledge about misogy, sexism, all these things, how women are treated, how they've been conditioned to behave. And then still you find yourself being like, but I really, really want this validation. Of course. And things like dating apps give us so much instant gratification, right, over these things that we then feel this need to like fake a peer. Like we need to fake our personalities, fake our prompts, fit in the mainstream, all of these things, right? But ultimately that is just serving a narrative that is not going to fulfill you. Yeah. And it's really hard to come to terms with that because what I always say to is healthy relationships are harder. I have found traditionally that when I have dated men and like kind of performed what it means to be like a heterosexual woman in 2024,
你可以掌握关于厌女症、性别歧视、所有这些事情的所有知识，女性是如何被对待的，她们是如何被规训成某种行为方式的。然后你还是会发现自己在想：但我是真的、真的很想要这种认可。当然。像约会软件这样的东西给我们带来了如此多的即时满足感，对吧，通过这些东西，我们随后感到了这种需要，比如去假装成另一个人。就像我们需要伪装我们的个性，伪装我们的提示，融入主流，所有这些事情，对吧？但归根结底，这只是在服务于一个不会让你感到充实的叙事。是的。要接受这一点真的很困难，因为我总是对人说的是，健康的恋爱关系更难。我传统上发现，当我跟男性约会，并且有点表现得像是2024年的异性恋女性时，
I've often found it easy because if they treat me poorly like ghosting behaviors or like poor conflict management, I'm like, you're the problem, you're emotionally unintelligent. when I've been in feminist relationships that really allowed me to be seen and heard, it turned back on me my own behaviours and issues when I was met with an emotional equal who challenged me in the way I challenge them. So it's actually quite hard to recognise when you're not having like the big sparks and the chemical reactions and you're actually in a feminist relationship where you're not playing into that internalised misogyny. Now you're presented with like, oh my God, there's so much I haven't discovered about myself
我经常觉得这很简单，因为如果他们对我很差，比如玩失踪（ghosting）或者糟糕的冲突管理，我就会想：你才有问题，你情商太低。而当我处于那种真正能让我被看到、被听到的女权主义关系中时，当我遇到一个在情感上与我平等、并以我挑战他的方式来挑战我的人时，这反倒让我开始审视我自己的行为和问题。所以，当你看不到那些巨大的火花和化学反应，而你实际上处于一种没有在迎合内在厌女情结的女权主义关系中时，其实很难去意识到这一点。现在你面对的是：天哪，我还有这么多关于自己的事情没有发现，
while I've been kind of suppressing and toning down and listening to that internal monologue. And what do they say? What's the happiest group of people on the planet? Single women in their 50s? Single women in the 50s. You're absolutely right. And it's the women who have been like, I've been there, done that, got the T-shirt. Yep.
而我一直在某种程度上压抑、收敛自己，并倾听着那个内心的独白。他们是怎么说的？地球上最快乐的人群是谁？50多岁的单身女性？50多岁的单身女性。你完全说对了。而且正是那些经历过“我经历过、做过、也拿到过T恤”的女性。对。
I sought the validation. I had these relationships that, you know, weren't feminist. And I'm opting out. Yeah. I'm opting out. Like, I just, I'm at the stage where I don't need that anymore. It's like, there will be Goldberg quote, like, I don't want someone in my house. Like, I don't want a man in my house.
我寻求过认可。我经历过那些你知道的并非女权主义的关系。而我选择退出。是的。我选择退出。就像，我只是，我到了不再需要那个东西的阶段了。这就好像乌比·戈德堡（Whoopi Goldberg）的那句名言：我不想让任何人进我的屋子。就像，我不想让一个男人进我的屋子。
I know, it's so clean normally. Yeah. It's all just, ugh. And you do like, and I feel like it's this whole thing where it's like, okay, I had kids and I got married. Yeah. So I did what you expected me to. But now you're, like, not paying attention to me because I've, like, aged out of the male gaze. So I can just chill.
我知道，平时它太干净了。是的。一切都，呃。而且你确实会——我觉得整个事情就是这样：好吧，我生了孩子，我也结婚了。是的。所以我做了你们期望我做的事。但现在你们，就像，不再关注我了，因为我已经超出了男性凝视的年龄范围。所以我现在可以放松了。
Yep. I can just chill and I can just, like, eat whatever the fuck I want. And I can look however I want. And I can wear whatever. colors and clothes. I don't have to be attractive anymore and I don't need to find a husband and I don't need to be a mother. But is still a mother, but is it then, like, and this is really the question, is it when the women who have found themselves in these predicaments who have sought out relationships, long-term monogamous heterosexual relationships, got married, had the kids,
对。我完全可以放松，想吃他妈的什么就吃什么。我可以想长成什么样就长成什么样。我可以穿任何颜色和衣服。我不需要再去迎合什么吸引力了，我不需要找个丈夫，我也不需要当母亲。不过，这依然是个母亲——但是，然后呢，这真的是个问题：当那些发现自己陷入这种困境的女性——她们曾寻找过恋爱关系、长期的单一伴侣异性恋关系、结了婚、生了孩子，
started to age out of that male gaze, and then discovered like it didn't matter, no matter what effort they put in it didn't matter anymore, that then become that internalized misogyny megaphone. Oh my God, do you think so? Like the women who are like holding on, the gripping, the remains of that feeling. Yeah, I think so. Yeah. And honestly, got it again with sympathy. That's what I mean.
开始超出男性凝视的年龄范围，然后发现这根本不重要，无论她们付出多少努力都再也不重要了——然后她们就变成了那个内在厌女症的大喇叭？天哪，你这么认为吗？就像那些还在苦苦抓着、死死拽着那种感觉残余的女性。是的，我也这么觉得。是的。说实话，甚至对她们产生了一点同情。这就是我的意思。
It must be awful. It must be so, so hard. And especially if you are still in the environments, like I'm thinking about where I grew up. And I grew up in, like, Queensland in Australia, which is like Florida, right? The Florida of Australia. I spend six years in Queensland, too. Yeah, and you grew up in like the fucking Alabama. I did. Orange, yes.
那一定很糟糕。那一定非常、非常难。尤其是如果你还身处那种环境中，就像我在想我长大的地方。我在澳大利亚的昆士兰长大，那里就像是佛罗里达，对吧？澳大利亚的佛罗里达。我也在昆士兰待了六年。是的，而你是在那种他妈的阿拉巴马州长大的。我是。橙县，对。
Orange. Yeah. We're not going to get into it. No, but we both have these experiences. Yeah. And sometimes I like see people from there who I'm just like, oh my God, I can just see that you're angry and you're angry because you don't know who you are and you're angry because you've been buying into the system, but you don't realize that's why
橙县。是的。我们就不深入讨论了。不，但我们都有过这些经历。是的。有时我看到来自那里的人，我就会想：天哪，我能看出你在生气，你生气是因为你不知道自己是谁，你生气是因为你一直在买账这个系统，但你却没有意识到这就是为什么
you're angry. Like you don't realize that like all of these feelings and this like hatred that you are projecting towards primarily younger women. And I see this a lot of older women in my like, where I grew up, all this anger that you're like projecting towards younger women is actually not, like you're not angry at them. Like you're angry that you didn't get that. And you're like, play by the rules because I had to. Yeah. I had to like do all these things that I'd actually, you know, innately like my deep inner like self, self concept did not want me to do these
你会生气。就像你没有意识到，所有这些情绪以及你主要投射给年轻女性的那种仇恨——我在我长大的地方的很多年长女性身上经常看到这一点——你投射给年轻女性的所有这种愤怒，其实并不是……你并不是在生她们的气。你是在生自己没有得到那些东西的气。而你会说：按规矩办事，因为我不得不这么做。是的。我不得不做所有这些其实我内心深处——我内心的自我、自我概念根本不想让我做的事情，
things because it wasn't free and it wasn't liberating. But I did them anyway. So now you should have to. And that's where I think it comes from. It is kind of this, we see this with the feminist waves too. see this regression almost where older women of previous waves resent the choices we now have and challenge that. And it's interesting because all I hope for myself is that when I become an older woman, that I champion the next generation of women. Yeah. And the changes they want to make because they might be different fights to mine, but they are reflective of the new frontier of what they're seeking next. And it must be hard to be left out of that. You have two choices, though. You can lie down and complain or you can get up and join them. Yeah. You know who I think is so,
因为这并不自由，也一点都不解放。但我还是照做了。所以现在你也得这么做。我想这就是它的根源所在。这有点像是——我们在女权主义浪潮中也看到了这一点。我们几乎看到了这种倒退，前几波浪潮中的年长女性对我们现在拥有的选择心生怨恨并对此提出质疑。有趣的是，我对自己唯一的期望是，当我成为一个年长女性时，我要支持新一代的女性。是的。支持她们想要做出的改变，因为她们的抗争可能与我的不同，但它们反映了她们接下来所追求的新前沿。而被排除在那种改变之外一定很难。不过你其实有两种选择。你可以躺平抱怨，或者你可以站起来加入她们。是的。你知道我觉得谁在这方面很厉害吗，
at that. I'm just going to give a shout out to my grandma who's like, oh my God, the truest feminist that ever fucking lived. Like, she is just so open and curious. And she, you know, she said this to me the other day. She's American. And she had to vote in the recent election. And she said, whenever I vote, like, I choose to vote for the person in who I imagine is doing it the hardest. And I think, how would they vote? And I vote that way. This is exactly. Exactly right. Use your vote for someone less privileged than yourself. Yeah. And she brings that to like her feminist principles as well, which she's like, I don't understand it. I don't know what you're doing, but like, cool, down for that. Don't care.
简直绝了。我要向我的外婆/奶奶致敬，她真的是——天哪，是有史以来他妈的最真实的女权主义者！她总是那么开放和好奇。而且她，你知道，她前几天对我说这个。她是美国人。她得在最近的选举中投票。她说，每当我投票时，我选择把票投给我想象中处境最艰难的那个人。然后我想，他们会怎么投票？我就那样投票。这绝对是。完全正确。把你的票投给那些比你特权少的人。是的。她也将这一点带到了她的女权主义原则中，她会说：我不理解。我不知道你在搞什么，但是——酷，我支持这个。我不在乎。
Her big thing is like cosmetic surgery. That's my big thing too, actually. Yeah. And she's, and that's like her big thing where it's like, it is the ultimate frontier of like, I think in my mind, like it's the ultimate frontier of incernalized misogyny versus like, freedom of women to do what they want, but then like are the insecurities only coming from, it's a whole. Well, I think that that's what the pick me conversation is about too, because are we just being sort of playing into the problem by criticizing other women, but then it comes back to this idea
她的核心执念是整容手术。这也是我的核心执念，其实。是的。而她，那是她的核心执念，就像：它是我心中终极的前沿，我认为它是内化厌女症与女性做自己想做的事情的自由之间终极的前沿，但随后，这些不安全感是否仅仅来自于……这是一个宏大的话题。嗯，我觉得这也就是“选我吧”（pick me）对话所关心的，因为我们是不是只是通过批评其他女性来在推波助澜，但这就回到了这样一个概念，
of what choice feminism is, which is the idea which I disagree with, that anything that a woman does is inherently feminist because a woman made that decision. But it's about individualism. It's about individualism versus collective action then, too. And when we are playing into a system that hates us, we are still feeding, monetising, and continuing a vicious cycle. And cosmetic procedures is another way. Pick me girls play into the male gaze. And it's not everyone that gets Botox or has cosmetic procedures is a picby girl.
即什么是选择女权主义（choice feminism）。这个概念我是不赞同的，即女性做的任何事情都天生是女权主义的，因为是女性做出了那个决定。但这是关于个人主义。这也是关于个人主义与集体行动的对立。当我们参与一个痛恨我们的系统时，我们仍然在滋养、变现并延续一个恶性循环。而整容手术则是另一种方式。“选我吧”女孩们迎合了男性的凝视。并不是说每一个做肉毒杆菌或整容手术的人都是“选我吧”女孩。
It's not what I'm saying. But we do need to assess at a higher level and step back from our immediate want to remove an insecurity and think, who am I doing this for? Yeah. And I think that's an exact, like the exact best way to think about it is, all right, this is still your choice. And it will always be your choice. But part of the choice is like a thought process behind it. With any choice, again, it's fact like the thing we were talking about with like marriage or choosing to be child free. Any choice, like you give up something and interrogating the reason that you choose to do something, I think is important.
我不是这个意思。但我们确实需要在一个更高的层面进行评估，从我们立刻想要消除某种不安全感的冲动中退后一步，去思考：我究竟是为了谁在做这件事？是的。我觉得这是一个最完美、最棒的思考方式：好吧，这依然是你的选择。而且这永远都会是你的选择。但选择的一部分在于它背后的思考过程。对于任何选择，再次强调，正如我们之前讨论的关于婚姻或选择不生育的事情一样，任何选择，你都会放弃某些东西，而审视你选择做某事的理由，我认为是很重要的。
And I know that like previously it was like makeup. I think we've all gotten to the point where like, no, no, makeup is self-expression as well as like a mask of an insecurity. And I wonder like where that discussion is going to go with cosmetic surgery. Because I honestly don't have an opinion on it. I'm completely stuck on the fence with it. I am anti-cosmetic surgery, but I love having conversations about this because I'm so willing to change my mind on this. And I think we should all be like that with a range of topics. but one of the conversations I had with a follower of mine when I was posting about this recently
我知道以前人们讨论过化妆。我想我们都已经达成共识了：不，不，化妆既是自我表达，也是对不安全感的一种掩饰。我在想，关于整容手术的讨论未来会走向何方。因为我老实说对它没有看法。我在这个问题上完全骑墙。我反感整容手术，但我喜欢就此展开对话，因为我非常愿意改变自己的想法。我觉得我们在这一系列话题上也应该都保持这种态度。不过，当我最近发帖谈论这个时，我的一位粉丝对我说过这样一番话：
was she said, you actually haven't aged yet. And so it's very easy from a 26-year-old's body to say I'm against engaging in and feeding into the anti-aging industry, the beauty industry, when actually you have the privilege of youth still and you don't know how you'll feel about your body and what that means to see a change down the line. I thought that was a fantastic criticism that really made me think about my argument. Wow, I've like never thought of that. I kind of got chills. Yeah, it's amazing. I don't think I've changed my position, but I've really thought about it.
她说，你其实还没老呢。所以对于一个26岁的人来说，站在这个年纪的身体里，说自己反对参与和助长抗衰老产业、美容产业，是非常容易的，而实际上你仍然拥有年轻的特权，你根本不知道当未来看到自己发生变化时，你对自己的身体会有什么感觉，那又意味着什么。我觉得这是一个非常棒的批评，真的让我开始反思我的论点。哇，我从来没这样想过。我甚至起鸡皮疙瘩了。是的，太棒了。我不觉得我改变了自己的立场，但我真的思考过这个问题。
And it's, I'm never applying a judgment to an individual for making the choice. I want us as individuals to come together and critique the system that has made us feel we need to do this. And the other thing that I actually saw someone, I had a similar conversation with someone offline. And she was like, okay, but don't you understand like being hot makes you powerful? So, and it's true. It's like, it is very, very true. So maybe it's like you embrace the evil for the good. I, on the fence about it, didn't agree neither, agreed nor disagreed.
而且，我从来不会因为一个人做出了某种选择而对其实施评判。我希望我们作为个体能够聚在一起，去批判那个让我们觉得自己必须这样做的系统。另外，我还看到过有人——我和某个人在线下进行过类似的对话。她当时说：好吧，但是难道你不明白，变辣/变性感会让你变得有权力吗？所以，这是真的。就像，这是非常、非常真实的。所以也许这就叫“为了更大的善而拥抱邪恶”。我对此骑墙，既不赞同，
I thought it was an interesting point. She was like, okay, if I want to be someone who breaks a glass ceiling, and that's the first step, right? We just want to break the ceiling, get the hole open so all the other birdies can fly out. That was not a metaphor, the woman. Just, you know, it was a metaphor for an atrium. I like that. I like that. Birdies. That's so funny. Anyhow. And she was like, okay, so if I want to be someone who can like walk in a room and like, you know, change policy or change, um, change, like, institutions or convince people to donate more to a charity or this or that or support the arts,
也不反对。我觉得这是一个有趣的观点。她说：好吧，如果我想成为一个打破玻璃天花板的人，而那是第一步，对吧？我们只是想打破天花板，把洞打开，好让其他小鸟都能飞出去。这不是一个隐喻，女士。只是，你知道的，这只是对中庭的一个隐喻。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。小鸟。太搞笑了。不管怎样。然后她说：好吧，如果我想成为那种能走进房间然后，你知道的，改变政策或者改变，嗯，改变，比如，机构，或者说服人们向慈善机构捐更多的钱，或者这个那个，或者支持艺术，
like if I'm hot, I can do that better. And so is that like, I've designed. I've designed. decided to play into the game for the greater good. And she made this like very interesting argument for it. I think it's a compelling argument, but I think it's immediately tarnished in a way by saying that is a woman locking the door behind her because there are other women who do not have the same privilege or baseline. Yeah. Because we know that pretty beautiful beauty exists on a spectrum. And as much as we want to say everyone's beautiful, we know that it's still hierarchical. and that Western beauty standards mean that it's like thin white women that benefit, right? Yeah.
如果我很辣/性感，我能把这些做得更好。所以这就像是——我已经决定。我已经决定为了更大的利益而玩这个游戏。她为此提出了一个非常有趣的论点。我觉得这是一个很有说服力的论点，但我觉得它在某种程度上立即被玷污了，因为这就等于是一个女性在身后把门锁上了，因为还有其他女性并没有相同的特权或起点。是的。因为我们知道，漂亮/美是存在于一个光谱之上的。不管我们多想说每个人都很美，我们都知道它仍然是有等级之分的。而且西方审美标准意味着，最终受益的依然是苗条的白人女性，对吧？是的。
And so I would always say like, of course, do what you want to do. I do want people to lean in if they want to wear a certain thing and fashion and make up art forms. But when we're talking about being hot and pretty privilege, yes, that's an argument that I think is really interesting to explore. But are you just, again, locking that door and pulling up the ladder from behind you for other women who cannot reach that same height? I'm going to bring that back to her. Maybe she's just listening to this episode. I want to see what she says. All right.
所以我总是会说：当然，去做你想做的事吧。我确实希望人们如果想穿某种衣服、想搞时尚和化妆艺术，就可以去倾心投入。但当我们谈论性感和美貌特权（pretty privilege）时，是的，这是一个我认为非常值得探讨的论点。但你是不是又一次在把那门锁上，为其他达不到同样高度的女性从身后把梯子抽走了？我要把这个抛回给她。也许她正在收听这一集呢。我想看看她会说什么。好啦。
I want to finish up by just talking about something that I get asked about a lot from listeners is a lot of my female listeners will be like, I've just started a new job, got my first big old job, I'm in the corporate environment, I'm in finance, I'm in whatever. How do I assert myself in this male-dominated space? Like, how do I say, I deserve to be here? without feeling like I'm going to be, I'm thinking about someone that messaged me recently. And I'm paraphrasing, but she was basically like,
我想在最后简单谈谈一个经常被听众问到的问题，我的很多女性听众会说：我刚开始一份新工作，拿到了第一份正儿八经的大工作，我身处企业环境，在金融行业，或者其他什么行业。我该如何在这样一个由男性主导的空间里展现自己？就像，我该怎么说：我配得上这里。而又不会觉得自己会——我想到最近给我发信息的一个人。我是在意译，但她基本上是说：
how do I do this? How do I stand out? How do I be myself without feeling like I'm going to be punished for that? I think that there's a few elements here. First is communication and I would say keeping records of things. That sounds a bit suspicious and all these things. But I think that in corporate workplaces, I actually used to work for a union and be like in sort of employment law.
我该怎么做？我该如何脱颖而出？我该如何做自己，同时又不用担心因此受到惩罚？我觉得这里有几个要素。首先是沟通，我会建议做好事情的记录。这听起来可能有点可疑，诸如此类。但我觉得在企业职场中，我以前其实在工会工作过，从事过某种劳动法方面的工作，
and defending people. So like a lot of my role was protection, self-protection for people. What I mean by this is when you want to prove what you're doing at work and assert your worth and the role you're playing here in this ecosystem, keep records of achievements, keep records of well-done projects and tasks, keep records of great emails, keep records of problems you find in the workplace. If you've asserted a policy problem, if you've asserted lacking organizations, if you've asserted concerns about a particular employee, like are you someone who's harassing you or something, keep a written record of what's going on is one thing. Two is make sure you're getting paid what you're worth. There is nothing like
并且保护过别人。所以我的很多角色都是为人们提供保护，自我保护。我的意思是，当你想要证明你在工作中做了什么，并彰显你的价值以及你在这个生态系统中扮演的角色时，请记录你的成就，记录表现出色的项目和任务，记录出色的电子邮件，记录你在职场中发现的问题。如果你指出了一个政策问题，如果你指出了组织上的缺陷，如果你指出了对某个特定员工的担忧——比如是不是有人在骚扰你之类的事情，保留所发生事情的书面记录是第一点。第二点是确保你的薪酬与你的价值相符。没有什么比得上
organizing like pay reviews six-monthly, talking about metrics, where your hierarchy work, what your dreams and visions are, what your plan is, what you actually are interested in pursuing your passions in the workplace and where you want to go. I think a lot of this, before we get to the stage of like, how do I assert myself at work, is getting really comfortable knowing what you're after. Because when you know what you're seeking and you have goals and you have a plan and an outline and you know what you're good at and you believe in that, that means that when you are in the workplace, you feel a lot more comfortable having tough conversations, whether it be with other employees in conflict, whether it be with management in seeking reviews, performance updates, going further
组织每六个月一次的薪酬复核，谈论指标、你的职级工作、你的梦想和愿景、你的计划、你在职场中真正感兴趣并想要追求的激情所在以及你想去哪里。我觉得这一切的很多内容，在我们到达“我如何在工作中展现自己”这个阶段之前，就是要对你追求的是什么感到非常舒适。因为当你清楚自己追求的是什么，并且有目标、有计划、有大纲、知道自己擅长什么并对此坚信不疑时，这就意味着当你在职场中时，你会对进行艰难的对话感到更加自如，无论是与发生冲突的其他员工，还是与寻求复核、绩效更新、在职场中走得更远的管理层。
in the workplace. But I think that this can be difficult because we know there's a lot of toxic workplaces around, but knowing your rights at work, knowing what you can and can't do, and knowing which boundaries you want to push, which boundaries you want to respect, and what you want to make change doing is incredibly important. Because I'm not going to say to you, like, get in there and go and start a fight or, you know, like get in the morning tea and, no, no. I think that we need to understand which rules are worth breaking and why. And I think we need to understand what we want from work because I think it's also about putting in place boundaries like, I don't go home after 6pm because I don't want to start setting the boundary
但我认为这可能会很困难，因为我们知道周围有很多有毒的职场，但了解你在工作中的权利，了解你能做什么和不能做什么，以及了解你想推动哪些界限、想尊重哪些界限、想通过改变实现什么，是极其重要的。因为我不会对你说：冲进去，去挑起一场争端，或者，你知道的，去茶水间大闹一番，不，不。我觉得我们需要明白哪些规则值得打破以及为什么。并且我们需要明白我们对工作有什么诉求，因为我觉得这也是关于设定界限的，比如：下午6点后我绝不回家工作，因为我不想开始树立这样一种边界——即我会为了加班而做任何事，而且我比其他人工作得努力得多。这里存在着一种微妙的平衡，我们要从“职场女性”（girl boss）时代中走出来。所以我们不希望人们为了碎银几两而在工作中拼命，被人踩在脚下。我希望人们通过把工作做好、问对问题、为自己争取更好并抱有期望、努力工作但也聪明地工作，来在职场中宣示他们的价值。我做到这一点的方法之一——我喜欢你刚才说的，你知道的，我们在告别“职场女性”时代。我们在向前迈进。
that I will do anything to stay back and I work much harder than others. There's this fine balance between kind of emerging out of a girl boss era. So we don't want people killing themselves at work for crumbs and being walked on. I want people to assert their worth in the workplace by getting things done well, asking the right questions, asking and expecting better for themselves, working hard but working smart too. One way that I do this, and I like what you said about, you know, we're exiting the girl boss era. We are moving on from that.
我们全心全意尊重我们作为人的自我价值，而不仅仅是机器。但在任何互动中，任何我必须划清界限的事情上，我只是想象我最钦佩的那个人会为我那样做。所以我想像——我试着想想我会为这个例子选择谁，比如职场例子，当我做管理咨询时，我曾有一位非常了不起的主管/经理。她的名字叫海蒂，简直是个传奇。有时当我要展现自我并说“不，我要回家，因为今天是我外婆的生日”或者“我要回家，因为种种原因”时，我就会想象她就在那里，然后说：“哦，对了，杰玛需要离开。”是的。
We're all about respecting our self-worth as people who aren't just machines. But in any interaction, anything where I have to assert a boundary, I just imagine the person that I admire most doing that for me. So I think like, I'm trying to think about who I would choose for this example, for like a workplace example, had a really amazing boss. manager when I was a management consultant. Her name was Heidi and she's just a legend. And sometimes when I'd have to like assert myself and be like, no, I'm going home because it's my grandma's birthday or I'm going home because of X, Y, Z. I would just imagine that she was there instead being like, oh yeah,
我就会在脑海中画面浮现，觉得她就和我在一起，或者我会想象我就是她。在这种情况下她会说什么？她会做什么？她会怎么表现？我在每一种情况都会运用这一点。这让我想起我去年对约会的态度是：成为你想约会的那个人。我喜欢这个。把它应用到这上面就是：成为你想雇佣的那个人。是的。所以这并不意味着一天工作14个小时。你不会希望你的员工那样的，因为我们不期望我们的员工那样，对吧？我们会希望有人按时上班，或者提前说明原因，沟通清晰、态度友善，把自己的个性带到工作中，尊重他人，进行精彩的对话，
by the way, Gemma needs to leave. Yeah. And I would just like picture that like she was right there with me or I would picture that I was her. And what would she say in that circumstance? What would she do? How would she act? I use this in every situation. It reminds me of like my approach to dating last year was be the person you want to date. I like that. Applying it to this is like, be the person you'd want to employ. Yes. So it doesn't mean working a 14 hour a day. You wouldn't want that of your employee because we don't expect that of our employees, right? We would want someone who turns up to work on time or lets us know why, communicates clearly, communicates kindly, has, you know, brings their personality to work, is respectful and has great conversations
并且做出高质量的工作，挑战自我。是的。这就是另一回事——工作确实感觉像是你个性的很大一部分，但它并不是你的全部身份。如果你把一切都奉献给职场，却不给自己留一丝空间，你实际上是无法成为一个能够高升的优秀员工的。所以我很喜欢这一点，对于自由职业者来说也是如此。我会想：我得听取我自己的建议。是的，不，这不适用于我们。哈哈。对，当然。哈哈。但我要说的另一件事是——这与所有这一切都有关。很多时候，我们的观点更加进步，我们会想：你会对你的朋友说什么？但是，为什么你没有把这些应用到你自己身上呢？
and does high quality work and challenges themselves. Yeah. And that's the other. thing is like work does feel like a huge part of your personality, but it's not your entire identity. And you actually can't be someone who is a good employee who's going to get ahead if you give everything to your workplace and leave nothing for yourself. So I love that as a self-employed people too. I'm like, I need to take my own advice. Yeah, no, it doesn't apply to us. Da. Yeah, of course. Dah. But that's the other thing I would say. And it's, it's to do with all of this. So often our views are more progressive and we would, what would you say to your friend? But not, what are you not applying to yourself?
在这些情况下，这也非常值得反省。我总是对我妹妹这样做。我妹妹是一名职业运动员。而我总是说：不，站起来为自己维权。别让他们对你颐指气使。要求更多的钱。然后在我自己的情况下，我就会像：喵，喵。我想我以前在这个播客里从来没有“喵”过，但事实就是如此。
in these circumstances, something to really reflect on too. I do this to my sister all the time. My sister's a professional athlete. And I'm always like, no, like, stand up for yourself. Like, don't let them boss you around. Demand more money. And then in my situations, I'm like, meow, meow. I don't think I've ever meowed on the podcast before, but it is how it is.
好了，我们要结束了，但我向每个人都问这个最后一个问题。我只是喜欢听听他们的想法。对于20多岁的人，你有什么建议？这不一定非得关乎我们今天谈论的话题。这有点随机。我其实从来没有在播客中以这种正式的方式给出过这个建议，这通常是留给我最亲密的朋友的。听起来可能会有点奇怪，因为这里有那么多更具鼓舞性、
All right, we're going to wrap up, but I ask this final question of everyone. I just love to hear what they have to say. What is one piece of advice you would have for people in their 20s? doesn't have to be about what we talked about today. This is a bit random. I've actually never given this advice, like, in a formal way, on podcast, is usually reserved for my closest friends. And it might sound a bit strange because there's so much more inspirational,
像Pinterest那样的内容我可以拿来分享。但在你们的关系中，你们的亲密关系中，无论是浪漫友谊，还是当有人在工作中经历激烈的冲突时，或者与他们的浪漫伴侣之间，我总是会问：你的底线（basement，字面意为地下室）在哪里？我的意思是：你愿意堕落到多低？因为我过去几年在约会、友谊以及其他事情中发现的是，当我在一段关系中感到心烦意乱、苦苦挣扎时，通常你是一点一点被消耗的，每次1%。
Pinterest-y sort of stuff that I could go for here. But in your relationships, your close relationships, whether it be romantic friendship, whenever someone's going through a hard conflict at work, whatever, with their romantic partner, I always say, what is your threshold at the basement? And like, what I mean is, how low are you willing to go? Because what I've found over the last few years in dating and in friendships and things is when I get upset in a relationship I'm struggling, often you're being depleted one percent at a time.
所以我想，哦，你知道，他们上周做了这个，这周又做了这个，但这两件事似乎都不足以成为引发问题或挑起冲突的充分理由。而最终经常发生的情况是，当你发现时，你已经被消耗了25%，却根本不知道自己是怎么走到这一步的，不知道所有这些1%的琐事、这些微小的事情是如何累积起来的，这时候把它们提出来会显得很荒谬，但我并不快乐。而我给出的建议是，在你的关系中非常清楚地找出你的底线在哪里。因为对很多人来说，底线是出轨，或者朋友以某种非常显著的方式从根本上背叛了你。我觉得我们需要提高我们的界限感，更好地了解自己，明确我们对关系的期望。所以，与其苦苦等待去发现那个底线（地下室），我会对人们说：明确知道你的底线在哪里。因为这能带给你一种自尊和理解。
So I think, like, oh, you know, they did this last week and they did this this week, but neither of those things feel like an adequate amount to, like, cause a problem over or start a conflict. And what ends up happening often is you end up 25% depleted and not knowing how you got there, how you're like all of these 1% items, these tiny little things have built up and it feels ridiculous to bring them up, but I'm not happy. And the advice I would give is to find really clearly where your bottom line is in your relationships. Because for a lot of people it's like cheating or like a friend like fundamentally betraying you in some like very significant way. And I think we need to improve our boundaries and understanding of ourselves and what we expect from our relationships. So instead of waiting to find the basement, I would say to people, know where your basement is. Because it allows you a sense of self-respect and understanding.
并且它能帮你更早地引发冲突和表达担忧。这是绝妙的建议。而且以前从没有人说过。哦，谢谢。这真的、真的是一个很好的建议。知道你的底线在哪里。你能承受多低，一个 limbo（林波舞，意指底线能压得多低）的笑话。我想这是因为我们常常发现自己会想：我真不敢相信我竟然到了这一步，因为这全是由7件小事或中等程度的事情造成的。
And it helps you raise conflict and concerns earlier. That's fabulous advice. And no one's given it before. Oh, thanks. It's a really, really good one. Know where your basement is. How low you go, limbo a limbo joke. I think it's because often we just find ourselves like, I can't believe I got here because it's seven minor or medium things.
是的。而且事情已经越过了底线，而你却不知道自己是怎么走到这一步的。我永远不希望人们有这种感觉。我确信听这集的你们，此刻脑海中可能正在想着你们自己的例子。就像在你们的大脑里，你们正在想着某个你们没有这样做过的友情、恋情、职场实例或邻居等等，而现在你们可以这样做了。是的。所以，汉娜，非常感谢你来到节目。
Yeah. And it's gone past the basement and you don't know how you got there. And I never want people to feel like that. And I'm sure people listening to this, you're probably thinking of your own example. Right now, like in your brain, you're thinking about a friendship or a relationship or a work instance or a neighbor whatever that you have not done this for and now you can do it. Yeah. So Hannah, thank you so much for coming on the show.
谢谢邀请我。我会在节目简介中链接每一个你可以找到她的地方，包括她精彩的播客《Big Small Talk》和《Big Talk》，还有……不久将推出的另一个。另一个。你大概能猜到它叫什么。是的。在评论区留下你们的猜测吧。
Thanks for having me. I'm going to link every single place that you can find her in the show description, including her amazing podcast, Big Small Talk, and Big Talk, and... Soon to be, another one. Another one. You could probably guess what it's called. Yeah. Leave your suggestions in the comments.
另外，我真的、真的很想对你们说，如果你喜欢这次对话，请关注 Chick Media，因为它太棒了。我就是从那里获取到那么多精彩的小信息片段的。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请务必给我们五星好评、关注、留言、留下一些暖心的话语。在 Instagram 上关注我们 @That Psychology Podcast。如果你想了解我们即将推出的新节目，如果你想发表评论或提出建议，
And also, I would really, really tell you that if you liked this conversation to follow Chick Media, because it's incredible. It's where I get so much little tidbits of information from. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, make sure that you give us a five-star review, follow along, leave a comment, leave some kind words. Follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to see what new episodes we have coming out, if you want to leave a comment or leave a suggestion
或者想就我们在这一集中讨论的内容进行讨论，无论你是赞同还是反对。无论如何，我们依然很乐意听到你们的声音。直到下次，注意安全。保持善良。当我们进入假期时，对自己温柔一点。我们很快、很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
or have a discussion about what we talked about in this episode, if you agree, if you disagree. We still love to hear from you regardless. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself as we enter the holiday season. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、体能以及建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。就在 IHeart Radio App、
an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world.
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个巨大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app,
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的最爱治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方其实都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男性背负着一副盔甲，它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吧？
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的天呐，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《陷入爱河》（Love Trapped）。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 23, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证是由人类制作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
我篡改了测试版。网络侦探们出动了一大批人，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。又有两个男人遭遇了同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens. finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终受到了惩罚。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。